possible contaminated jif peanut butter
products sold across the nation and here
in the valley jeremy j ford spoke with a
family who discovered a jar they were
using could have salmonella as a parent
as someone that
sees these recalls often i i personally
didn't take it very seriously lisa matt
recently checked her jar of jiff creamy
peanut butter and found it to be in the
recall range of possible salmonella
contamination my daughter's been having
stomachaches and i thought oh man maybe
that's the reason tuesday after packing
a peanut butter sandwich for her
daughter she says she referenced the
recall dates and the label and lo and
behold it was it was affected it was
part of the recall which is why she
booked an appointment with a
pediatrician and notified friends i said
hey send me pictures of your peanut
butter labels let me check
and sure enough a girlfriend of mine
that shops at a different smith's she
had the sugar-free gif and hers was also
part of the recall now her message
especially with more gif products on the
list just be diligent check check your
pantries and pay attention to the
recalls it's important and it's for your
own benefit and for the benefit of your
children jeremy j ford live local now
eight news now reached out to the
southern nevada health district who
tells us that this time they have no
reports of salmonella cases in our area